today's topic a woman asked me why don't
men open up to me more in romantic
relationships and I'd posted a tweet
right now basically said okay the reason
why men don't open up mostly is because
men treat their emotional sanctity the
way women treat their sexual sanctity
right and when you give up either before
you're comfortable it always makes you
feel she's lightly cheapen absolutely I
agree
i yo what you mean go ahead you said
everything that don't have to be said it
right there all right
it was like I was doused and well near
genius my dude right and the last line
it says is we men will open up but it's
only when we want to and how we want to
and one thing I really want to tell
women is like when it comes to emotions
and what we go through men are talking
about it just when you're not there we
feel comfortable talking about it
amongst each other right because it's a
space where we feel like we can
communicate and we won't be judged for
how we do it do you talk about your
boom-boom smell which is another no but
you probably talked about it with your
girlfriend
why because they have poom poom as well
and they might understand right you like
yo girl Sarah would you get your poom
poom fragrance and she's like man I was
at Chanel I went to Bed Bath and boom
boom yes funny a girl one time she
bought me something called older xx yeah
and I said why do you buy toilet water
because that's how it translates to
friends I really thought oh when you're
where Alice is yo I'm not even that
intelligent
[Music]
I was a little unnecessary but okay no
I'm not why did you buy me toilet what
can i order 20 translate this is toilet
water isn't that a terrible name yes the
French people cause it's just because of
the history of what it is you want to
know what they call their favorite
sandwich
I cook mister you're gonna cook mr.
meets and croque monsieur is bite mister
it's even worse yeah but they have that
the same thing with an egg on it it's a
croque madame which means bite missus
the reason is we call the cut my time
because there's a man on it still nasty
anyway side bar side yeah i said this
and a lot of people went crazy in the
comments and one thing I've noticed is
whenever I talk about men's
vulnerability and how we feel
comfortable relating this stuff a lot of
women feel very comfortable interjecting
and telling us what it should look like
how comfortable give you guys an example
of comment one the idea that women are
cheapen for having intercourse early in
a relationship is incredibly just first
off I didn't say anything wrong with you
sleeping early with a man there's
nothing wrong with it if you want to
sleep with people early on that's okay
there's nothing wrong with that but when
you sleep with somebody before you're
comfortable and ready to do so you do
feel cheap because you were pressured
doing so maybe because either because
they pressured you because society
pressured you but there was some kind of
pressure you regardless of that you did
it before you wanted to do it yes so but
shouldn't get that and she said this
mindset that you men have is the reason
why relationships fail communication is
necessary for any healthy relationship
human connection and that's going to
require that one of the parties make the
first move to be vulnerable men should
get used to doing that because they're
in the relationship two women should not
be and are no longer being okay with
bearing the brunt of emotional carrying
the relationship and laying down the
initial emotional foundation for the
relationship then you shouldn't date
those men if you don't like the pace
that they're going at don't take them
the same way if I meet a girl she says I
want to meet till marriage I don't force
my way on them I don't tell them what
they have to change I said I accept the
fact that we have a difference in how we
view things and I'll move on with my day
it strikes me as odd that you say that
men are the reason why a lot of
relationships are failing because
they're preserving their emotions
there's not one thing why are you
putting that kind of pressure on men
they will open up when they're
comfortable the same way ladies you will
sleep with men when you're comfortable
and it's fine
I don't endorse men pressuring new
ladies the same way I don't endorse
y'all pressuring us I've done that
before why because of society's
messaging and because the person I was
with I opened up when I knew I wasn't
ready and it made me feel sick and I
didn't want to be around that person
because I felt like they saw me naked in
a way that I wasn't comfortable with you
see ladies you know you know when you
you you open up mmm you know when you
have angel questions before your time
yeah and that is backfires and the guy
calls you XYZ after that you were not
ready you did it you feel cheapen and
now that is being used against you that
feels bad I have a lot of my girlfriends
that it was done to I've seen that and
that is bad
yeah well imagine that whenever you open
up before you're ready and that is used
against you after that how you feel is
the same thing that's why I love the
parallel that you did when you did that
I was like ah that's Jeep that's exactly
the same thing you have to be ready to
open up yeah and also it's opening up to
women because we're fine with opening up
to other men generally it's just a y'all
because it's a different thing it's a
different way of communicating so it
takes us longer it's not because it's
something against women it's just
because you are different there are some
things there are some things that we're
gonna have to explain to you just
because you don't understand same with
us there's some things that women have
to explain to us because we do not get
it yeah you guys we will never
experience it you guys are probably way
more comfortable discussing certain
experiences with other women faster and
it's understandable yeah I feel the same
way about people in the military I'm
much more apt to talk to them about my
experience because they understand it I
don't like talking about it with
civilians it feels weird same thing with
my experience growing up in Ethiopia
it's much easier to talk about it with
someone's from there in that same token
men have certain shared lived
experiences that they can understand
that's all it comes down to so
understand that men aren't afraid of
being vulnerable we are capable
we're just not necessarily comfortable
with it another thing to also
acknowledge is that ladies you claim you
want a vulnerable men but sometimes you
shame us and I've done another video on
this way interviewed women they talked
about it where they've laughed at men's
vulnerability where they said it was too
much so it's like yeah show me what's on
the inside but then when you look you
like that was too much well that kind of
makes us feel some type of way that's
what we asked for look in those comments
of that threat so many men were post a
man I've opened up to a woman and she
used it against me later on
that's a frustrating and scary thing to
do to be like I'm gonna show you where
my weak point is and then when I'm not
ready for it you stab me right there
doesn't make me want to show you where
my weak point or future people where my
weak points are right so we all have
some work to do we all have some work to
do because you can say all you want
there's so many women I know like I want
a man to be as vulnerable as he can be
cool stories a lot of y'all say that and
then when it happens you find yourselves
grossed out and you don't acknowledge
the fact that you've engaged that
behavior well you've psychologically
told that man that what he did was wrong
so of course in his future relationships
he's not gonna do it listen I've done
that whole thing I've done that SOI boy
who opened my heart up right off the top
let her know the things and she wasn't
okay with him part of it was my fault
but also her reaction was crazy and look
I learned from it now it doesn't mean
that now I never opened up I do but I
wait until I'm ready you said SOI boy
yeah yeah toy boy toy boy toy boy when
you know yeah you just was a little boy
soybeans for bean yeah so I just want to
give you guys that experiment that
perspective understanding why we are
different and how that manifests but go
talk to your guy friends all the ones
that you think never talk about their
emotions I promise you if they do talk
about it it's with other men and if they
don't it's healthy to talk about it with
other man yeah if you don't have an
outlet please please do find one that's
whether it's a support group whether
it's an online form whether it's other
men that you can see in regular person
or best friend whatever it is find a
confidant yo and also didn't have if I
didn't have all the people that I have I
would actually fake that I'm an out
to go through Alka a meeting oh yeah I
would if I didn't have a support group
I'm at a job I wouldn't fake you I'm mad
at you and also the other thing I would
say is like this is divide along gender
lines but there's some women who are
like this as well and there's some men
who were extremely comfortable to be
like this is what I'm feeling
ah right like a giant Care Bear just
shooting feelings out his chest good for
you but most of us are this way and so
yeah I just want y'all to know and
understand it a little bit better is
there anything you think you think they
should know about vulnerability I think
we sum it up you have this group where
we talk about her stuff like that and
that that's though no when we when we
met right after like when everything was
it was allowed to mean everything and
stuff yeah it was good to just talk
about different stuff and talk about how
we live this it's just different it's
just different from a male perspective
yeah if male understand it yeah I'm
gonna talk about it with my significant
other because it's a some other thing
but there's some things that she's not
gonna be able to understand no remember
I told you guys things that I've
literally never spoken to with anyone in
my whole life ever and for me it was a
space where I felt comfortable because I
knew I wasn't gonna be judged some type
of way and I knew that you guys could
understand even the way I communicate
and I need that we all need that you
know so I just want to shed a little bit
light on on men's vulnerability and that
whole idea and yeah you know I think we
could all do better even me you know
there's been times in my life where I've
been a little bit ashamed of my own
behavior so I'm not doing this to cast
stones is just to let you guys know what
it is that we live so guys if you guys
agree with this if you guys feel the
same way please share your stories below
let other people be able to read some of
your experiences it helps other people
to realize oh this is a real thing the
same way the meet tooth movement mean we
realize a lot of bad male behaviors you
know I mean this is a chance for you
ladies to recognize a lot of male
experiences and what they go through
right so that's all so let us know what
you guys think in the comments below I
look forward to reading them
[Music]